this video is sponsored by kimura do you
like to run around naked me neither i
prefer wearing clothes whenever i can
help it but who says you have to look
like a tarnished peasant mucking about
in the slop just for the sake of being
not naked why not wear something that
fits nicely while looking absolutely
divine that's where kimura comes in they
use only premium materials like the
absolute finest cotton for their clothes
be it a t-shirt jacket hoodie you name
it and they care so much about their
products that they even hand package
each one of them before sending them off
to soon to be transformed lowly
tarnished peasants and i would know
since i've received several shirts from
them and speaking from firsthand
experience they are indeed quite soft
and comfortable with fitting nicely
around the chest and shoulders area and
tapering off at the midsection which is
a very popular cut for many people i'd
do a little catwalk strut for you but i
don't want to get the video demonetized
and also they have better looking models
than me on their website but that's
besides the point the point is letting
kimura clothe you with their premium
products at much better prices than
other premium clothing companies and
what's more is that if you go to
camera.com and use the code bandit at
checkout you will save 10 off your
entire order which will then arrive to
you with speedy shipping and a full 100
refund satisfaction guarantee not that
you'll need it so what are you waiting
for ah rise now you tarnished and let
kimra clothe your naked writhing bodies
and now on to the video
hey everyone bandit here eldon ring is a
weird game in the lands between we see
all sorts of stuff like trees with dead
people making up their roots demigods
that ride tiny malnourished horses a
turtle pope that i would gladly give my
life for frog people that cart wheel
aggressively towards you and so much
more amidst all of this weirdness though
fans were very quick to point out that
there seems to be somewhat of a pattern
to it one that feels a bit familiar the
weird world of eldon ring has so many
callbacks and shoutouts and parallelisms
to its equally weird spiritual
predecessor series called dark souls and
i already know what a lot of you are
thinking lots of fans out there and i
mean lots of fans out there are very
adamant to say the least regarding the
notion that eldon ring is definitively
100 without a doubt a different universe
than dark souls altogether based off of
a quote from miyazaki and that's fine
eldon ring is still different enough
that i totally understand why you'd like
to believe it's a different universe
entirely so that you don't get a
headache trying to figure out how it
could be connected totally fair it does
say in the very beginning of the reveal
trailer that eldon ring takes place in a
quote new world created by miyazaki and
r.r martin and miyazaki himself has
never said that they are connected
universes but
i just so happen to think that it's also
important to note that he has not
confirmed they're separate either so in
this video i'd like to remain a bit more
topical than usual and state my train of
thought and reasoning for why i think
eldon ring and dark souls have to share
a universe from both in-game lore
discoveries and real-life discoveries
and if you've ever found yourself even
the least bit curious about why these
games feel a little too familiar to one
another you'll probably enjoy what i
have to say oh and spoiler alert for the
video you've been warned even before any
interviews or theories started to take
place fans like myself had already felt
that there was a connection between the
franchises and honestly once the game
actually released these feelings were
nothing but strengthened like i was
mentioning earlier the worlds of these
games are extremely similar but just in
case some people aren't on the same page
here let's cover a few of the
aforementioned similarities in dark
souls you've got women trying to become
fire keepers and in elden ring you've
got women trying to become finger
maidens and their purposes are very
similar the land of lothric from dark
souls 3 is described as being the land
where the lords converge and the lands
between from elden ring is described as
being a land between the hollows of dark
souls are cursed humans and the
tarnished of elden ring are also cursed
humans gwyn committed the first sin in
dark souls by creating the dark sigil
and merica committed the first sin in
elden ring by shattering the elden ring
and the list of similarities goes on and
on and on of course they're not
perfectly similar to one another like
for instance there's no grace in dark
souls and there are no bonfires in eldon
ring but the fact remains that they're
definitely more similar than not but see
because of that if we are still to say
that this is truly a wholly separate
universe devoid of any lore connecting
the two then for them to share all of
these similar concepts and themes is
kind of lazy world building isn't it i
mean that would be like some creative
genius let's just say michael jackson
making the hit song billie jean saying
the kid is not my son and then some
years later making billie dean saying
the girl is not my daughter and claiming
that it's a brand new concept that's
never been seen before in his previous
works everyone would know that even
though it's a new song it's not actually
a new concept it would clearly have to
have been inspired greatly by what came
before and i think this is true for
eldon ring i think it is extremely
inspired by the universe of dark souls
but i also don't think miyazaki and
funsoft are lazy developers that copy
and paste world structure and concepts
from game to game and just rename the
concepts and then call out a different
ip altogether and because of one
specific quote from a very influential
creator of eldon ring i also take it one
step further and believe it is
legitimately connected in the lore some
of you already know who i'm about to
quote it would be the legendary writer
george r.r martin himself but i don't
think the quote actually came from him
originally
let me explain as everyone already knows
martin was recruited as one of the two
head writers for the universe of eldon
ring specifically he handled the mythos
of the world or the setting and universe
building while miyazaki and the rest of
the team from fromsoft handled the
actual nitty gritty story and in an
interview with martin about eldon ring
he said this but the game is called the
elden ring and it's a sequel to a
video game that came out a few years ago
called dark souls
all right that's all i've got for this
one pack it up folks we're done here is
what i would say if i didn't know for a
fact that there are some of you who are
automatically going to go down in the
comment section below just to claim that
george rr martin didn't actually know
what he was talking about or that he
just meant it wasn't an actual sequel
but like a kind of sequel a spiritual
sequel a sequel in a sense but i'm sorry
i just have to disagree because of
several reasons the first of which being
that the man the myth the legend grrrm
doesn't actually play video games
personally that's i i don't play many
video games literally a few seconds
earlier in the interview he said this
well it actually is considerably
different i've played some video games
i'm not a big video gamer i don't play
many video games i'm not a big video
gamer now i'm not trying to be
stereotypical but what i think a man in
their 70s means by saying oh i've played
some video games before is that they
mean they've played like galaga or maybe
even the original legend of zelda my own
analytics on this very channel tells me
that people in his age group are almost
completely uninterested in these kinds
of games and
wait this is weird it also tells me that
90 of my recurring viewers are not
subscribed to my channel wow really 9
out of 10 people i hope those people
know that a subscribe helps the channel
out so much on the algorithm and that
they can always unsubscribe later if
they change their mind that i am and
would be eternally grateful if they did
choose to subscribe please subscribe i
need friends i think it's extremely safe
to say that mr martin has not played any
of the soulsborne games namely any from
the dark souls franchise which has only
existed for about a decade if he had
played the fromsoft games before he
would have mentioned that he was a fan
of those games or maybe even the company
but instead he says he's largely
unfamiliar with video games as a whole
and then explicitly states that eldon
ring is a sequel to dark souls let me
ask you this how would a man that is not
familiar with a video game franchise or
games in general know that he's working
on the sequel to a video game i mean i
guarantee you that he didn't just pull
that out of his ass and say even though
they said over and over that they just
want me to create a new world i feel
like it's probably you know a sequel to
this other game that they made called
dark souls not that they brought it up
at all this is just me pulling it out of
my ass there's only one actual logical
answer as to why he said that he must
have been told that it was a sequel when
he was asked by miyazaki to write for
the game or in other words the fact that
it is a sequel came from the word of
miyazaki himself with this in mind all
of a sudden even though there was a new
world built for eldon ring all of those
parallels between it and dark souls
start to make sense and that's just the
conceptual parallels there are several
things that eldon ring has in common
with dark souls that implies a specific
shared lore base for instance in the
original dark souls if you descend down
this giant hollow tree called the great
hollow you will find yourself in ash
lake where there are countless other
giant trees called arch trees
mysteriously and specifically spaced out
from one another in a lake of water
extending for an unknown length into the
distance and sky above many fans over
the years have come to the conclusion
that these arch trees are inspired by
real-life norse mythology where the
giant all-encompassing world tree known
as yggdrasil supports the entire world
on its branches their actual purpose
isn't confirmed of course as is common
with lore in these games but that's
actually besides the point the point is
whatever these trees are they make a
straight-up reappearance in eldon ring
it's debatable whether they appear under
the ground in the eternal cities as
these structures look to be pillars made
of rock instead of wood but the
undebatable blatantly obvious appearance
of the arch trees comes at the final
boss as the elden beast materializes in
front of us we can see in the background
all sorts of equally spaced trees
extending from a lake of water
limitlessly into the distance and sky
it's quite clearly supposed to be some
sort of big reveal at the climax of the
game and i can't help but feel that
whatever they are they connect to the
arch trees and therefore the universe of
dark souls and speaking of trees you
know how it's super weird that whenever
you see roots of the great tree in the
dungeons of eldon ring it's always shown
to be like made of dead bodies and also
how when you die you sprout little
saplings of another earth tree implying
that in this universe trees come from
death well this whole body's equal
sprouting trees thing actually started
in dark souls there are bodies of
hollows that are shown to have sprouted
into trees once again implying that the
rules of the world function the same
human life is reborn into trees but okay
enough about trees in dark souls there
are also three kinds of magics sorceries
miracles and pyromancies in elder ring
there are two sorceries and incantations
which are literally the combination of
miracles and pyromancies from dark souls
which let's face it was probably
simplified for gameplay reasons the fact
that sorcery is specifically an
intelligent scaling shared school of
magic between the games and incantations
that scale with faith are the combined
miracles and pyromancies from dark souls
also implies very heavily that the game
universes are the same after all none of
the other fromsoft games share these
schools of magic except for the miracles
and demon souls but we'll get to that
possible connection later the enemies
that are also shared between the worlds
make sense too and this is possibly one
of the biggest reasons to believe that
eldon ring is connected to dark souls
the literal nearly picture-perfect
reappearance of rats or large rats or
slimes or man serpents or undead dogs or
crabs or giant crabs or sentinels is
more than just a coincidence and then
there's the appearance of perhaps the
most notable and infamous dark souls
monsters of them all the basilisks you
know those bug-eyed lizard-bodied death
farters that ambush you in all the wrong
places there even still straight up
called basilisks and still curse you
with death if your blight bar fills up
exactly like their dark souls
appearances both of the universes also
share the ancient dragon lore where in
dark souls the dragons once ruled the
world with impenetrable stone scales
that gwen figured out how to defeat and
an elven ring long before the age of the
herd tree dragons ruled the world and
used to have you guessed it stone scales
like i said earlier i refuse to believe
that fromsoft is just a lazy company
they are more than capable of creating
brand new enemies for each of their
brand new ips like they've done time and
time again you are kidding yourself if
you think they just copy pasted all of
these monsters and their lore from dark
souls because they ran out of time or
some other lazy reason which means that
the monsters reappeared for a reason
besides the monsters there are also some
specific names and even possibly people
that show up in eldon ring from dark
souls for instance in the southern
weeping peninsula there's a castle
called castlemorn uniquely spelt
m-o-r-n-e within which there is a lady
named irina who's trying to become a
finger maiden this is quite peculiar
because in dark souls 3 there's a man
known as aegon of karim or igon of
kareem however you say it who wears
morn's armor also spelled uniquely
m-o-r-n-e and is protecting a lady named
irina who's trying to become a fire
keeper coincidence i think not and some
of you have heard about the speculation
surrounding the dung eater because of
that emblem on his chest the blank-faced
sun emblem on the chest of the dung
eater is stupidly similar to the
blank-faced sun emblem on the chest of
solaire of astora i'm not saying that
this means definitively that they're the
same person or related to one another
but you've gotta admit this is just
blatant i mean it would be like another
zelda game coming out being called
something else but then featuring the
freaking hylian royal crest on someone's
shield or body armor certain things are
just too blatant and even if they're not
related to one another they clearly
share a belief in the sun since it is
said that the dung eater once drew
guidance from that very emblem oh and i
had mentioned earlier that i would talk
about the possible connection to demon
souls and it's not very substantial but
it is extremely cool even if nothing
more than a nod or a reference the demon
soul's theme is literally in the eldon
ring theme no joke take a listen
[Music]
[Music]
pretty freaking cool right and of course
the final connection that i'll mention
is patches good old trustworthy patches
but at the end of all these discoveries
and similarities the biggest question of
them all remains and that is how we can
sit here and call out every single thing
that dark souls shares with eldon ring
and trust me it's a lot but it feels
like it's all for nothing if we can't
explain how they're connected and this
is where things get extremely
speculative perhaps dark souls took
place before elden ring as a result of
one of dark souls 3's endings perhaps it
took place after as a result of one of
elden ring's endings probably the fire
one perhaps elden ring's multiple
different endings lead to the multiple
different ips but on the other hand
maybe we don't actually have to figure
this out see lots of people myself
included tend to get all caught up with
trying to answer the question of whether
or not dark souls takes place before or
after eldon ring as if it's all on one
big timeline but one thing that's clear
from the structure of all these games is
the fact that there have always been
lands outside whatever land the game
takes place in in dark souls there are
the distant lands of astora or karim or
katarina in elden ring there are the
distant lands of the newman or the reeds
in demon souls the whole game is
composed of five different worlds the
point is it's always been a blatant fact
that other lands or worlds exist within
the same universe and who's to say how
far away these other worlds are i mean
kratos from god of war can eliminate the
entire greek pantheon and then just
travel far enough to enter the world of
norse mythology complete with its own
set of rules and gods so why can't
something similar be possible for the
universe of eldon dark demon souls ring
this means that it doesn't matter which
game took place when because they don't
necessarily have to happen in the same
lands or worlds and therefore are not
necessarily directly connected to one
another while also explaining how they
are all indirectly connected to one
another if that makes sense so
tldw the worlds of dark souls and elder
ring have way too much specific stuff in
common to be a coincidence george rr
martin confirms eldon ring is a sequel
to dark souls and it's entirely possible
that the games are all connected by
universe but take place in different
worlds that's just my theory though what
do you guys think is eldon ring
connected to dark souls or is this just
another case of wild fan speculation
over a bunch of weightless references
let me know in the comments below and
seriously thank you so much for watching
please consider leaving a like on the
video if you enjoyed it or if you
enjoyed my efforts into making it and
subscribe if you haven't already for so
much more to come huge thanks as always
to my bandit crew of which i have the
new name of astrolink83 to announce
that's all i've got for this one so as
always i hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day this is bandit looking
forward to seeing you next time and
signing out peace
[Music]
you